[Musique]
bienvenue dans cet entretien politique
avec jean michel fourgous bonjour
bonjour alors on va revenir un peu sur
votre front votre parcours à travers un
portrait qu'on a réalisé vous pourrez
interrompre que vous voulez pour donner
des précisions pour corriger si vous
voulez des des choses qui nous
paraissent inexactes et puis on
terminera en parlant aussi un peu
d'actualité parce que c'est une
actualité importante entre la situation
sanitaire l'économie et les deux sont
indéniablement liés on va commencer si
vous voulez bien part parce ce portrait
qui s'appelle la politique autrement
[Musique]
maire d'elancourt depuis 1996 président
de saint quentin en yvelines est réélu
pour la deuxième fois dans cette
fonction il a aussi été député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
la première fois c'était en 1993 près de
trente ans de vie politique donc avec
pas mal de succès et quelques revers
mais qu'est ce qui fait courir
jean michel fourgous quelles sont les
raisons profondes de son engagement
politique et les convictions qui fonde
son action
c'est ce que nous allons tenter de
comprendre ensemble tout commence à la
fin des années 80 né à montreuil dans un
milieu modeste
jean michel fourgous a ratissé du das
saison il a abandonné ses études il est
rentré chez ibm au bas de l'échelle
comme co midi et après il a repris ses
études plus tard mais je pense que cette
période de sa vie a été déterminante
dans ses idées qu'il ya aujourd'hui de
se dire oui avec l'informatique à
l'époque on disait pas numérique
l'informatique on peut acquérir des
compétences
au plus rapidement j'étais une seconde à
cette question d'études que vous abordez
il y avait des matières dans lequel vous
étiez doux et d'autres moins mais au
fond c'est passé c'est l'enseignement
qui vous à qui vous a déçu oui c'est la
méthode la pédagogie du prof
c'est très français s'est d'ailleurs de
pas savoir valoriser un enfant et est
donc j'étais pas très bon à l'école mais
j'étais parmis à ses formes et cécile
commandes pourquoi pourquoi parce que je
vais le parlement français quand je levé
la main pour poser une question
la prof était à fond nous devons alors
allez-y poser de questions alors quand
matt c'était à jean-michel s'il vous
plaît silence on écoute jean michel dit
mais comment est ce que on peut envoyer
une telle différence de messages selon
le prof
alors je suis devenu fort en maths alors
je sais pas si je suis venu faut
remettre par seulement positif
oui mais mais mais mais quand même je me
suis dit je me suis pour tous les
français il faut changer ça et j'ai
quitté le coach mike ricci bm mais sur
deux saisons et puis après vous avez
pris vos études obama côté de regarder
ça après cette scolarité interrompue il
reprend ses études il deviendra docteur
en psychologie sociale et ingénieur de
recherche à l'éducation nationale mais
surtout il fonde une pme qui emploie 25
personnes et créé des logiciels de
gestion de ressources humaines
une entreprise innovante qui reçoit
d'ailleurs un soft d'or récompense
attribuée à ce qu'on n'appelait pas
encore des start-up une entreprise
marche bien mais un contrôle fiscal la
fragilise d'administration peut donc
sanctionné une entreprise qui investit
dans la recherche et personne ne peut
s'opposer à la toute puissance des
fonctionnaires c'est donc pour se battre
contre des décisions qu'ils destinent à
juste qu'ils entrent comme on dit en
politique
alors on va écouter nicolas david dans
un instant b c'est bien ça cesse et
c'est cette injustice quand il vous dit
comment on peut changer les choses quoi
oui mais surtout
le fait de voir que l'état dit la
recherche vous avez 25 personnes dont la
moitié étaient des chercheurs vous ne
pouvez pas déduire comme le crédit impôt
recherche un mettait la partie numérique
se passer le parti la partie du hc rien
n'arrête la recherche c'est le premier
des multiplicateurs d'intelligence
d'innovation au monde en est content
l'état qui vous dit à ce moment là non
ce n'est pas imputable et smain jour
redresse rejet d'une petit pays
redresser toutes les stars choice
d'accès pas que les gars sentiment
d'injustice quoi c'est ça dedans oui oui
j'avais à dire je dis comment il se dit
que les tests sont ainsi décaler des
réalités de l'entreprise nous on avance
on fait avancer le monde star et tous
mes copains qui sont aussi bien sûr en
bété comme ça ils me disent que comme on
a parlé de moi parce que j'ai eu le soft
de relationnel bon alors ils me disent
beaucoup de ce que tu as fait beaucoup
de médias vas-y bon et est pris en tant
qu'homme députés lors des coups tu me
connais ma ville et on parle justement
jean michel fourgous il s'est engagé en
politique parce que c'est un chef
d'entreprise qui a vécu
de manière très concrète je dirais les
affres une administration qui parfois
est plus punitives que facilitatrice
pour les chefs d'entreprise il s'engage
donc et il mène le combat
nous sommes en 1993 jeu sera bientôt
l'heure de la deuxième cohabitation
la droite va triompher le ps s'effondrer
et comme jacques chirac
échaudé par l'expérience de 1986 ne veut
plus entendre parler de matignon
françois mitterrand va nommer edouard
balladur premier ministre
mais si la droite est favorite dans
certaines circonscriptions
elle est aussi divisée cela dit comme en
france tout marche par deux la gauche
aussi est à l' ces désaccords
le casting de cette élection est
impressionnant à gauche ni malandain
député sortant représente le parti
socialiste harlem désir qui deviendra le
premier secrétaire de ce même parti
porte pour l'heure les colleurs de
génération écologie nicolas bour maire
de montigny qui a été député de la 8e
circonscription et qui deviendra par la
suite
sénateurs puis membre du csa et candidat
dissident cu d
à droite c'est jeanine cahier
conseillère municipale de trappes
membres du parti républicain qui obtient
lors de ce premier tour
l'investiture de l'ue pf c'est à dire de
la majorité udf rpr et dans cette
élection personne ne voit venir ce
candide encore inconnue et nouveau
politique qui s'appelle jean-michel
fourgous et qui pendant sa campagne
parle essentiellement d'entreprises et
d'encours pourtant au premier tour
énorme surprise avec moins de 200 voix
d'avancé sur jeanne in cahiers il est le
mieux placé des candidats de la droite
la campagne cependant a été rude et les
morceaux ne seront pas faciles
la reconnecter sur son bulletin de vote
il avait fait apparaître en très gros
rpr udf
ce qui était un moyen de laisser
imaginer aux électeurs qu'il était lui
même le candidat de l'udf mon communiqué
est clair à titre personnel je ne
voterai pas pour monsieur fourgous mais
je ne voterai pas non plus pour de
sémalens dan jean michel fourgous se
reconnaît d'ailleurs que le combat n'a
pas été de tout repos
c'est vrai que c'était un petit peu
qu'une fois conflictuelle mais bon les
électeurs ont tranché a eu accès c'est
ça la règle démocratique s'est pas
uniquement les partis qui font qu'ils
font les élections on reconnaît le
personnage plein de plein de courage
beaucoup de avec beaucoup de volonté de
détermination
et puis un peu de gens me dire avec du
pif
c'est à dire qu'il avait senti que cette
circonscription pour en faire quelque
chose et donc il est parti tout seul
et comme il est arrivé au premier tour
je crois qu'il a fait un très bon score
au premier tour en 1993
bien évidemment d une investiture entre
les deux tours le ps lui apporte donc
son soutien entre les deux tours et
c'est jacques toubon qui viendra faire
campagne avec livre le résultat sera des
plus serrés 50 97 % fourgous 49,03
ballon d'un soit 616 voix d'écart
députés sur ton semble faire contre
mauvaise fortune bon coeur la politique
c'est comme ça ce sont des victoires et
des défaites il faut jamais attendre en
politique le remerciement de ce qu'on a
fait pour ses concitoyens dans
l'immédiat je vais chercher du travail
lors de cette législative pour quelques
40 voix la ville d'elancourt est passé à
droite
c'est sans doute ce qui va convaincre
jean-michel fourgous de se présenter
deux ans plus tard contre le maire
socialiste alain d'années dans un
premier temps celui-ci remporte les
élections
mais le scrutin est annulé et les deux
hommes se retrouvent à nouveau face à
face au début de l'année 1996 et cette
fois c'est jean michel fourgous qui avec
123 voix d' avance remporte le combat
évidemment la courte victoire laissera
quelques traces au point que le nouveau
maire propose une commission municipale
ouverte à l'opposition
aussi vous dire devant le sénat fait
effectivement un tirage est une aubaine
utile
moi je propose du gars qui est plus de
transparence jeu différente
l'opposition exprimée et bien vérifier
les informations
vu dans cette campagne alors juste juste
petit possible quand vous êtes présenté
aux législatives
pourquoi vous avez choisi d'abord cette
circonscription est est ce que vous
aviez le sentiment que vous pouviez
gagner d'abord que j'avais les mois
j'avais des certitudes j'avais des
convictions cimenté dans l'épreuve de
l'expérience et de cet échec que m'avait
fait vivre un peu l'administration
ça vous donne et ce sentiment de de la
justice c'est une force extraordinaire
mais vous aviez regardé politiquement
comment ça vous trouvez ce patient la
direction oui mais ça vous n'êtes jamais
situé non loin alors en fait c'est un
peu ambigu cette histoire mais ça peut
oublier en fait on me l'avait donné la
prévision ensuite on là parce que yen
autres dirigeants qui voulaient voir les
deux instituts rivotril aucune chance
pour bush on lui enlève droite mais
comme quoi bon mais je dirais c'était
parce que cette séquence offensive et
beaucoup de pme moi je venais de la pme
ma femme à dire ma femme aussi avait
aussi un penny et loyaux on était
vraiment complètement imprégné de cette
culture qui qui fait donner le meilleur
de soi aux hommes dans les petites
entreprises
les rapports sont très direct vous voyez
les réalités c'est pas lui c'est pas du
blabla et et ça je sentais que cette
circoncis ressembler et et oui c'est
pour ça que vous l'avez vous l'avez
choisi et puis après il va y avoir la
mairie de laon couvron côté de la
regarder de combat difficile non mais
finalement deux succès que le taux en
tout cas pour la mairie d'elancourt va
pérenniser le scrutin qui va arriver
après on va nous permettre de nous
représenter surtout d'être élue dès le
premier tour ce qui veut dire que les
airs comptoir était séduit quand même
perdre notre méthode par la méthode
aussi de jon fosse
comment expliquer d'ailleurs cette sorte
de fidélité de ses électeurs est lent
courtois je pense que la première des
vertus de jean michel fourgous qui
explique l'ensemble de ces élections
depuis effectivement sa toute première
élection acquise j'ai à dire dans la
douleur c'est sa capacité de savoir
s'entourer deux aspects chez lui
important d'abord c'est un visionnaire
c'est là que c'est plus un homme de
grands dossiers mais de perspectives il
a été le premier par exemple avoir tout
l'intérêt du digital dans l'enseignement
il a été le premier à voir tout
l'intérêt de reconstruire un
commissariat et on voit bien aujourd'hui
dans l'actualité ce que représente
l'importance pour les forces de l'ordre
d'avoir un comme sa digne de ce nom de
couvrir un territoire c'est un homme de
couverture plus généraliste et de visu
et de vision j'ai à dire nationale voire
internationale
je prendrai le cas de l'impôt recherche
et en même temps ce qui explique que
localement il est toujours été réélu
c'est que c'est un homme qui sait
s'entourer d'hommes et de femmes de
terrain ce sont les équipes qui sont
avec lui qu'il a su bâtir pour
renouveler changé m aux affaires qui lui
assure effectivement cette réélection
est d'ailleurs jeu direct dans une ville
qui est plutôt j'allais dire de
tentations plutôt de gauche il est réélu
alors que c'est un homme de droite on
voit bien là que c'est la gestion du
terrain qui lui permet cette réflexion
brillante au premier tour à chaque fois
le succès ne se rappelle même aux
élections législatives on se souvient de
la dissolution décidée par jacques
chirac en 1997
ce qui fera dire aux mauvaises langues
qui vient d'inventer le septennat de
deux ans la vague rose qui va amener
lionel jospin à matignon est cette fois
trop forte pour quelques 5 163 voix
catherine tasca remporté l'élection
c'est bien la preuve que cette 11e
circonscription est un peu particulière
pour c'est une circonscription assez
difficile qui prend le vent comme on dit
en politique c'est à dire quand il ya
une élection présidentielle en général
le député et de la couleur politique de
l'élection présidentielle le récente
donc pourquoi c'est une vraie question
parce que il n'y a pas beaucoup de
circonscriptions comme ça dans la noue
dans la dans les yvelines dans le
département je pense ma plus tôt c'est
sa sociologie célestine sociologie très
coupée en deux avec d'un côté une partie
plus tôt
on va dire versailles grand parc une
partie plutôt ville nouvelle et donc il
ya très très fort équilibre il ya une
très bonne balance qui s'effectue alors
cette balance un peu penché d'un côté
elle peut peut pencher de l'autre le
balance il continuera 2002 réélection de
jacques chirac et victoire de jean
michel fourgous 2007 victoire de nicolas
sarkozy et réélection de jean michel
fourgous 2012 élection de françois
hollande et dont la 11e circonscription
de benoît hamon 2017
l'élection d' emmanuel macron
s'accompagne d'un raz-de-marée des
candidats north marche ou bénéficient
nadia et celle ci devenu ministre de la
ville devra toutefois abandonner son
siège et lors d'une élection partielle
c'est philippe benassaya candidat du pnr
qui dope portera juste un bout sur sept
c'est vrai c'est une circonscription
assez particulière dans les yvelines un
il ya des circonscriptions qui sont
alors il eut le raz-de-marée macro nist
en 2017 et un peu particulier mais sinon
il des circonscriptions qu'ils ont
plutôt à droite et celle là elle elle
balance en fonction de la tendance
polymathique nationale un kyste et m
c'est étonnant comme un mois c est vous
allez donc ça dépend pas de votre bilan
des dépôts du coup sa survie c'était une
circonscription très difficile et c'est
pour ça que ce soit pas trop embêté ce
que je me suis présentée plus ou moins
on n'allait pas vraiment l'investiture
bon et on m'a quand même
entre guillemets l'essai et c'est aussi
avancer parce que parce qu'il pensait
que il y avait une chance d'abord elle
avait jamais été voilà c'est telle
qu'elle était à l'époque n'avait pas été
nourri au contenu
voilà pour les combats politiques les
élections les campagnes intéressant
d'ailleurs de savoir comment cet homme
qui se méfie du superficiel qui préfère
parler et convaincre plutôt que de
serrer des mains fait campagne
ce qui est terrible et jean michel
fourgous et que nous nous faisons
beaucoup de porte à porte
d'ailleurs c'est la meilleure des écoles
je veux dire de commerce pratiquement
c'est une élection municipale à
elancourt nous allons voir 100 % des
habitants chez eux prend peur
d'électoral et lorsque l'on fait ses
campagnes jean michel fourgous
on voit tout l'appétence fila dans ces
opérations de porte à porte tant et si
bien que cantons suisses un objectif de
voir 31 ans courtois
quand on arrive à en faire deux avec lui
c'est du monde et un délai qui les a
tendance à rester pendant une heure une
heure et quart à discuter avec les gens
a alors apporté la contradiction au
contraire les rassurer du coup on fait
moins de portes voyez ce il a ce côté
passionnel du discours et du dialogue
avec les autres qui du coup montre son
appétence pour les campagnes toral et je
dirais qu'il adore un peu le nador ont
également ce combat rhétorique bien
souvent il va aller chercher notre
opposition dont conseil municipal mais
pour pouvoir essayer de les persuader
en fait il ne renonce jamais à persuader
y compris ses plus farouches opposants
il aurait peut-être meilleur pu tenter
de reconquérir ce siège de député
aujourd'hui le mandat unique empêchera
peut-être de se représenter bien que
quelque part il en a envie mais il fait
un travail tellement extraordinaire dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qu' il est déjà très pris par
ce mandat
je pense que jean michel fourgous appris
aujourd'hui la la juste mesure du rôle
de ce qu'est un président d'une
communauté d'agglomération comme saint
quentin en yvelines de tout ce qu'il ya
à faire du côté passionnant il a fait un
grand nombre de mandats à nombre
important de mandat en tant que député
il a également pu prendre bien entendu
là la tendance et se rendre compte
concrètement de ce qu'on pouvait faire
en tant que député pour moi il est passé
à autre chose
il est passé d'une phase où on va
proposer des lois on va modifier ses
lois on va les amender ce sont des lois
très généraliste
je pense qu'il a fait son temps sur ce
sujet là et qu'il a voulu revenir à des
choses beaucoup plus concrète et
j'allais dire que et j'allais dire que
et je suis désolé pour mes amis députés
ça ne plaira pas forcément un président
de deux pci de communes d'agglomération
de métropole aujourd'hui deux
communautés de communes a plus
probablement de pouvoir pour le coup à
faire concrètement sur le terrain à à
anticiper à agir qu'un député qu'il va
bien souvent levé la main avec ses 200
autres collègues pour adopter un
amendement qu'il aura écrit ou qu'il
aura porté mais qui sera longue et un
peu dans une masse
je veux redire là sur cette saison
olivier dassault d'ibra peut-être qu'il
aurait bien aimé redevenir députés
laurent mosar idy n'ont finalement c'est
peut-être plus concret ce que vous
pouvez faire sur un territoire que qu'à
l'assemblée web seulement sur devienne
député mais j'étais à côté de lui même à
la fin avant d'ensemble 250 députés
aujourd'hui à 100 quand j'étais
président après donc il faut débuter
pour les présentes séries qu'ils
président il m'a tout de suite nommé
directeur gilles très très réglo dire
gégousse d'un pied d'ailleurs s'ils ont
le fric est donnée par un affidé ans
c'est vrai que quand on est député alors
même si on va revenir sur des choses que
vous avez faits dont l'amendement
fourgous en est c'est un oui mais joue
un rôle important en parler mais mais
c'est vrai qu'on est un parmi d'autres
quand on est président d'une dune
l'agglomération saint quentin maire de
villeron voit peut-être plus directement
le fruit de son action non nommés de
descamps président d'une agglomération
comme saint quentin en yvelines
honnêtement il faut le dire c'est un
petit joyau exécutif ça n'a rien à voir
avec les députés dans l'opposition déjà
les députés n'ont pu régner et non leur
donner la parole
il n'y a que 2 % des lois qui sont fait
parler sur l'inspiration des députés
donc voilà ici
ici nous avons une équipe qui tient la
route une cohérence des très belles
entreprises abonnés d'alice prix est la
preuve
moi j'ai même donné des postes de
vice-président à tout le monde est là et
ça fonctionne voilà vous avez plus de
jeu le dire c'est un mot un peu
compliqué moi vous êtes autre atout
psychologique
il est plus heureux n'ai rien à voir
j'ai été trois fois député mais
aujourd'hui députée vous avez une
buvette un pub pour les copains et puis
les prétendus 8e étage et puis des
voyageant en classe affaires pour faire
le tour du monde bon franchement c'est
bon c'est pas mon truc
par contre fait réussie crise crée des
emplois d'avenir et de stratégie
numérique ça c'est vraiment l'avenir de
la france c'est le plus grand des
multiples numérique c'est le plus grand
des multiplicateurs d'innovation
d'intelligence de 2 de croissance dieu
sait si on a besoin de croissance pour
rembourser les baies pour pour redonner
ce pays toute la vigueur qu'il aurait
jamais dû perdre mais voilà donc moi
aussi je suis très heureux alors
justement on va parler du fond de votre
engagement
peut-être en effet cette passion du
concret s'exprime-t-elle plus
directement à la tête d'une mairie ou
d'une agglomération que dans une
majorité parlementaire est cependant
avec génération entreprises associations
de parlementaire créée avec olivier
dassault hervé novelli associations
espas des clivages politiques
il est parvenu à convaincre des députés
jusqu'à leur sceptiques que s'intéresser
au monde des entrepreneurs
il a créé effectivement avec olivier
dassault et hervé novelli à l'époque ce
groupe de deux députés issus du monde de
l'entreprise qui sont très minoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale qui est un monde
dont les députés représenter en tout cas
à l'époque davantage le monde
administratif et il a créé ce groupe là
pour essayer de changer les choses
changer concrètement les lois génération
entreprise c'est une une force
d'intervention c'est aussi une
passerelle tout simplement entre le
monde politique et le monde économique
ou entre le monde économique et le monde
que nous parmi les textes portés par
génération entreprise
il y en a un qui est presque devenu un
nom commun puisque on dit qu'on peut
fourgous et son assurance vie et c'est
l'amendement fourgous
c'est vrai que l'amendement que nous
avons co signé mais ce qui nous fait
toujours sourire et jean-michel parce
qu'il porte le nom du premier signataire
donc très gentiment on le présente comme
la demande mans fourgous d'assaut c'est
l'amendement fourgous et donc ça ça a
été très importante pour revitaliser le
tissu industriel précisions sur les
chiffres
c'est 100 milliards pour la science en
vient donc et cette fin fond du problème
est plus que c'est en fait entre 500
millions et 1 milliard mais parce que ça
provoque des tours de table donc vous
arrivez avec colliers 7pm le mec avait
donc ilaria et hop ça déclenche est en
même temps du tour de table dès que vous
arrivez à oui mais bon mais déjà
l'importance sur l'assurance-vie
fédération des nations unies bien plus
de 100 milliards mis en images
on doit être à 110 mais toutes sont
milliards c'est le moment car c'est de
la grosse au four ousmane d'origine
parlementaire est d'origine
parlementaire une fois que ce truc parce
que est il du sang sur les murs faut
pour faire passer ça vraiment régler ça
a été
révolution les types de figures des
finances n'y croyais pas et est courtisé
de quoi il va ruiner le budget français
il va prendre l'argent voulait parler
mais c'est nous à bercy parce que quand
des finances c'est géraud les parce
qu'il garantisse la dette comme ça ils
peuvent endetté le payer ils ont ils
utilisent la garantie de de l'épargné
des français donc je dis non l'épargné
penser à une partie qu'ils vont aller
renforcer le capital de nos entrées 9,0
du stress sont deux à quatre fois moins
capitalisées que leurs concurrents
anglais a le moins bien qu'un donc
c'était sale et on a réussi
mais vous avez réussi malgré merci aux
faut il faut il faut s'imposer quoi
parce que la berline parce qu'il ya une
veillée d'administration très forte on
va d'abord avec des gens très diplômés
des inspecteurs des finances et ramé qui
tiennent au fond bercy si on s'impose
pas et d'ailleurs tout ce qui a été
ministre de l'économie le 10 ans ils
n'arrivent pas à s'imposer très vite
après ces fichus quoi le poids de
l'ennemi à jouer parce que moi il était
tout seul moi je suis un collier été
bien appuyé le groupe parlementaire oui
c'est ça tout ça à plat aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas cité on serait jamais passé
wifi sans sa production cette cour des
comptes nicolas donne des précisions
justement jsf pme pour que l'argent des
riches comme on dit financent les
les petites entreprises et puis le
crédit impôt-recherche le crédit impôt
recherche
on s'est battu avec jean michel fourgous
depuis 1995 avant même génération
entreprise existe déjà 1,95 à l'époque
nous étions trois survie qu'hervé
novelli
et lorsque nous avons recréé en 2002
après la défaite 97 lorsque nous sommes
revenus au parlement
nous sommes battus pour élargir
l'assiette de ce crédit impôt recherche
et surtout le faire perdurer au delà des
majorités et là c'est quelque chose qui
a été formidablement encourager et nous
a fallu 12 ans de bataille sur ce sujet
et c'est en 2008 que nicolas sarkozy lui
donne sa véritable dimension dimension
qui a perduré sous françois hollande est
également sourds emmanuel macron une
précision sur ce que dit olivier
dassault qui parle de nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque la ministre de la recherche
c'est valérie pécresse oui la diversité
de leurs versions wii et je vous
prendrai louis lui je faisais ancien
patron de hre nous disait la meilleure
le crédit impôt recherche c'est la
meilleure mesure politique qui était
prise dans les 15 années et il faut le
rappeler
certes génération entreprise d'assaut
fourgous voilà aimé mais c'est pécresse
ministre de la recherche qui nous
autorise vraiment à faire passer et qui
est qui qui fait passer la
transformation multiplie par dix le
crédit impôt recherche pour les
entreprises comme beaucoup de chercheurs
et s'abaisse l'équivalent des charges
patronales et savoureux mais un même
niveau que que les autres pays et là on
redevient compétitif l'intelligence on a
protégé l'intelligence française les les
brevets c'est une nuit parce que la
recherche est essentielle mais c'est
grâce quand même à pétrole restent fort
bien
ok autre cheval de bataille de jean
michel fourgous le numérique
à l'époque anne k piou qui devient après
ensuite adjointe au maire d'elancourt et
conseillère départementale spécialiste
de digne gastou dirigeait l'association
des parents d'élèves il m'a demandé si
j'étais d'accord pour diriger une
association qu'il inventait à l'époque
s'appelait initiative terrain et qui
avait pour objet de développer justement
le numérique dans les apprentissages
scolaires
on a travaillé avec un laboratoire de
lyon qui a développé un logiciel qui
s'imprime même aux ors et qui
développait les différentes facettes de
la mémoire donc auditive visuelle etc
donc on est parti au départ sur ce
projet là où on a équipé une école qui
était l'école des petits prêts à
elancourt dans un quartier un petit peu
compliqué à l'époque et on a équipé une
salle avec 25 ordinateurs à l'époque je
m'en souviens c'était noël avant l'heure
parce qu'on avait on a mis une vraiment
beaucoup de matériel et on a fait
travailler différents groupes sur sur ce
sur ce logiciel
on a fait un certain nombre d'auditions
pour essayer de voir comment ces
nouveaux outils pédagogiques pouvait
améliorer le plaisir d'apprendre le
plaisir d'enseigner et augmenter les
résultats scolaires de tous nos enfants
il faut peut-être préciser ceci que ce
qui nous paraît aujourd'hui aller de soi
était dans les années 90 assez novateur
à l'époque jean michel fourgous quand il
parle du numérique à l'école
tout le monde le prend pour un
hurluberlu c'est effectivement ça des
cas ça décoiffe c'est vraiment une
innovation dont on a très très peu
entendu parler et il va prendre ce thème
à bras le corps
je crois que à l'époque une enseignante
l'avait dit voilà il faudra me me passer
sur le corps pour mettre en place ces
outils numériques dans nombre
d'établissements mois vivant que jamais
et au final tout le monde a suivi mais
c'est vrai qu'il a été un vrai père
précurseur il s'en est saisie avec un
esprit d'innovation pour ce que chacun
que tous les acteurs de l'éducation se
rendent compte de l'importance du
numérique mais de l'innovation à l'école
de manière générale et aujourd'hui je
dirais le l'idée était considéré comme
farfelu puis innovantes et puis
maintenant c'est une idée très répandue
et dont beaucoup de villes de france
s'en empare avec beaucoup de réussite et
de bien dire que que là vous voyez
l'égalité des chances c'est gai c'est
que que le prof vous trouve sympathique
ou pas vous avez un outil devant vous
vous pouvez apprendre à votre rythme
revoir le soir c'est complètement
différent
est ce l'effet pygmalion non je vous ai
parlé et c'est extra dire et c'est le
meilleur outil pour lutter contre
l'échec scolaire
c'est pour ça qu'ils montrent les
scolaires contre les inégalités
d'origine parce que c'est vrai que ça
fait sauter des des classes presse que
j'allais dire un aux enfants les plus
qui sort de milieux défavorisés
sa seule des fautes qu'on peut dire
c'est que on le voit par brel en
kouroussa du pied même plus dix ans
c'est qu'on fait fin après la terminale
baccalauréat on convoque les on invite
les jeunes qui ont passé leur bac avec
mention bon et on s'aperçoit que là ils
ont une orientation professionnelle ils
ont décidé d'une ambition nouvelle qui
est très scientifique tandis que ça
stimule l'aquilion scientifique discret
c'est indiscutable alors il me faut des
collégiens qui devient super ex armée
mais pas écoutés
bon je pense que si c'est le seul crédit
qu'on veut faire écouter gestuelle un
bond à paris saclay ou plus qui peut les
accuser universités scientifiques et
techniciens au monde
voilà une cohérence un boxer corée il
était persuadé que en amenant le
numérique dans les apprentissages
scolaires il a vite compris que ça a
mené une autonomie d'enseignement on
n'apprend pas tous au même rythme on est
d'accord donc le numérique permet
l'autonomie des élèves et permettent de
travailler à son rythme et selon ses
compétences
deux missions parlementaires seront
consacrés au sujet j'ai participé avec
jean michel fourgous à 2 2 deux missions
parlementaires une en 2009 qui était le
thème c'était la porte de l'outil
numérique dans l'informatique et à
l'époque effectivement on avait
rencontré jean 1 jean michel blanquer
il était à l'époque directeur de la
dgesco au ministère et voilà il nous
avait bien aidé d'ailleurs dans dans les
différentes conversations qu'on avait
eue avec lui et la deuxième mission
parlementaire c'était en 2011 et là
c'était bon maintenant on a prouvé que
l'apport du numérique dans les
apprentissages scolaires était déficient
maintenant on va on va on va adapter la
pédagogie à l'outil informatique
on apprend plus les enseignants en
apprendre plus aux élèves en classe
pareil avec l'outil numérique amendement
rapport parlementaire est toujours de
fortes convictions
la première qu'il faut moderniser le
pays et que l'utilisation des outils
numériques va permettre de faire
franchir une étape et aussi de gommer en
partie des inégalités sociales la
seconde qu'il faut laisser des chefs
d'entreprise créer une richesse dont
tout le monde profitera deux idées
fortes qu'il va pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
sur ce territoire
c'était pas quelqu'un hors sol qui
parlait de grandes idées nationales il a
toujours essayé de mettre en pratique au
local et notamment à elancourt puis à
l'échelle de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les grandes idées qu'ils défendent et
c'était le cas avec le numérique
certes il y avait la mission
parlementaire au niveau national mais y
avait je dirais à elancourt le
laboratoire d'innovation réel et c'est
pareil au niveau économique il défend
des des grandes idées sur l'entreprise
sur l'entrepreneuriat sur l'innovation
mais il a pu les mettre en pratique en
tant que vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines au développement économique
et ensuite de président de saint quentin
en yvelines avec la création du ski cube
pour avoir ce guichet unique pour nos
entrepreneurs avec la soirée des
entrepreneurs pour pour essayer tous les
ans de le promouvoir
je dirais les bonnes idées à mettre en
pratique pour nos entrepreneurs de
renforcer le sentiment d'appartenance
pour deux chefs d'entreprises sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis là on l'a vu aussi sur les
écoles du numérique l'ouverture des
écoles de formation au numérique pour
des profils qui sont pas forcément
diplômés qui sont parfois en décrochage
parfois il suffit de nos quartiers et
pour qu'il puisse avoir une formation
sur des métiers qui sont très recruteurs
et donc c'est effectivement moi ce que
j'ai beaucoup apprécié chez l'homme jean
michel fourgous c'est qu'il ya les idées
il ya le combat qui mais de manière très
très pugnace mais il ya aussi la
réalisation le concret tantôt de dresser
un bilan
homme de droite libérale la réalité est
peut-être plus complexe
ce n'est pas un ultralibéral cc c'est un
homme qui pense que les idéaux libéraux
peuvent aider la république l'état et
que le service public peut aussi aider
le l'entreprise le privé et donc c'est
cette alchimie là qu'il essaie depuis
des années de produire dans notre pays
c'est un libéral c'est un homme de
droite c'est un homme qui a la foi
libérale mais néanmoins qui est plutôt
de droite sociale
j'ai à dire c'est un homme qui est assez
complet et si je voulais un petit rien
pu que j'avais même que on l'a vu sur le
par exemple d'édition culturel on peut
dire que ça peut même être un homme de
gauche
d'ailleurs la gouvernance qu'il pratique
est à cent lieues des affrontements des
premières campagnes puisque sur les
quinze vice-présidents de saint quentin
en yvelines quatre appartiennent à
l'opposition à saint quentin en yvelines
jean michel fourgous s'est révélé comme
j'allais dire pratiquement un homme du
centre mais au bon sens du terme capable
de composer avec tous deux donné il a
été quasiment le premier à le faire des
vice-présidences à ces oppositions de
travailler au quotidien avec elle donc
c'est un très bon exemple la nation dès
qu'on revienne là-dessus parce que c'est
vrai que à un moment vous avez pu avoir
une image un peu pas tellement
consensuelle et au fond quand vous êtes
comme d'être président de de saint
quentin vous avez fait venir il ya
quatre vice présidents qui sont des élus
de l'opposition qui travaillent avec
nous nous ces moyennes entreprises jeu
plus intrusive league
l'entreprise vous dit ce qui est bien ce
qui est mal ce qui est vrai et ce qui
est faux il ya beaucoup moins de jeu
qu'on peut trouver avec une dialectique
est très très politicienne franco
français sur je me retrouve pas l'astuce
pour sakho comme je peux dire est que
bettina un peu bon mais oui voilà par
exemple vous me connaissez toutes les
communes de gauche et droite sont
représentés voilà c'est la première fois
que ils ont ils ont des vice présidents
et vice-présidents c'est pas les paris
mais pas d'un mois je
mais parce que je pense que c'est quand
on fait confiance aux gens à mes trois
enfants j'en ai trois joueurs je leur
fais confiance au temps en temps il faut
un peu plus de tirs mais mais et c'est
pour ça que vous dis-je parce que la
droite la gauche mais c'est vrai que
j'ai l'impression que la droite fait
fait confiance d'abord fait confiance à
l'entreprise que c'est le lieu où où un
homme qui a une idée rencontre un homme
cas de l'argent à un homme qui valait
faire un réseau commercial et c'est
comme ça que vous créez et vous trouvez
des meilleures solutions que celles qui
existent pour la vie des gens pour
améliorer la vie des gens et c'est vrai
que c'est un laboratoire extraordinaire
pour développer l'intelligence humaine
sont changés responsable donc donc voilà
je sais pas si c'est ça être libéral
mais il faut donner une liberté minimum
minimum est ce qu'un enfant il faut
fixer des règles mais il ya des rémois
je suis très laide sua et concept gauche
de droite du centre de champhol jadis a
été volée si wallace au quotidien
faire de la politique pour convaincre
donc convaincre de l'importance de
convertir notre pays à la révolution
numérique et de faciliter la vie des
entrepreneurs parce que ce sont eux qui
créent la richesse
et faire de la politique autrement qu'en
adoptant des textes préparés par de
jeunes fonctionnaires sortie tout frais
de l'ena mais qui n'ont aucune
expérience du terrain consacrera
d'ailleurs à cette mainmise de la haute
administration sur la politique
un livre virulent écrit avec gregor
bourgeois et jean michel fourgous plaide
d'ailleurs avec nôtre et qui sortent de
plus en plus nombreux pour la
suppression de cette école il le run à
clore un peu comme moi sur sur cette
formation unique qu'elena pour coller
pour les fonctionnaires et il a raison
je pense que l'école nationale
administration n'est plus adaptée aux
enjeux d'aujourd'hui
faire de la politique autrement c'est
aussi s'entourer de personnalités très
diverses et mettre le pied à l'étrier à
la nouvelle génération
c'est quelqu'un qui décloisonne qui
n'est pas dans une logique de hiérarchie
ou de verticalité il est beaucoup plus
horizontale il implique beaucoup ses
équipes dans ces rendez vous dans ces
projets il s'entoure de gens très très
différents quel que soit parfois même
leurs idées politiques ou leurs origines
il aime avoir une équipe de genres
différents il disait toujours le
meilleur talent c'est de trouver les
talents exemple de l'actuel député de la
11e circonscription qui fut le directeur
de la communication de la ville des noms
j'ai été sollicité dans un premier temps
par la ville d'elancourt pour travailler
collaborer sur des sujets de
communication voilà comme un client si
vous voulez à l'origine et puis cette
sas et au fil de nos conversations avec
jean michel faure où je me souviens son
propre le premier rendez vous qu'on a
eue c'était la buvette de l'assemblée
nationale un soir il devait être entre
deux séances je sais de quoi je parle
on va souvent la buvette pour pour entre
deux entre deux séances et il et il m'a
dit voilà si je pouvais éventuellement
aller plus loin qu'une simple
collaboration entre clients et agences
et j'ai accepté j'ai accepté parce qu'à
l'époque et l'encours était dans une
dynamique numérique une dynamique
vraiment politique intéressante et
cetera j'acceptais pour conclure
laissons la parole à deux personnalités
incontournables et de ce territoire et
de la politique française
d'abord la présidente de la région ile
de france valérie pécresse
les portes des fabuleux projet pour
l'avenir
le projet de la colline d'elancourt qui
va devenir la colline du vélo en
ile-de-france et en france ce sont des
magnifiques projets et je ne vous parle
pas évidemment de toute l'éducation
numérique que nous déployons lui dans
les collèges et les écoles et moi dans
les lycées de la case qui est des
yvelines ensuite gérard larcher
président du sénat je le connais bien
d'abord
c'est un homme qui est pensent que
l'économie c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel et qu'on ne bâtit rien sans
une économie qui tient debout il a pas
tort vous ne luttez pas contre la
pauvreté vous ne lui étaient pas contre
le chômage
vous n'avez pas des progrès dans la
société sans une économie qui soit
soutenue c'est un homme qui croit aussi
dans les vertus de la science mais aussi
et en ces temps où nous voyons que nous
avons besoin de la science pour nous
sortir de la pandémie et de maladie je
crois que ça fait partie de ces valeurs
c'est un homme en plus extrêmement
présents sur le terrain extrêmement
enracinés dans dans sa ville d'elancourt
au fond c'est un maire c'est aussi un
homme qui a une vision nationale
notamment au plan économique mais aussi
très attentif à son territoire alors il
est plutôt d'une pièce parfois mais ça
fait partie de ses qualités
et moi je les ai toujours soutenu on ne
se ressemblent pas tout à fait c'est
vrai et mais je dois dire que c'est une
chance là aussi pour ce territoire à la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin qu'il puisse faire partie
comme chef d'equipe de tout l'été qui
cette équipe de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin on ne
se ressemblent pas dès 10 heures la paix
c'est vrai qu'il est peut-être plus de
politique comme comme on l'entend
généralement que vous mais au fond il
voit là il reconnaît que l'action que
vous avez donnée pour les autres prises
pour le numérique notamment c'est
important et que vous l'amenez aussi sur
ce territoire
mais je suis moins rond cuisson
joundallah mais ces sénateurs c'est
quand même beaucoup plus politique moi
je suis beaucoup plus direct presque
sujet verbe complément dans l'entreprise
on appelle ça m'a beaucoup marqué les
meufs sait on se parle directement on se
raconte pas de blabla on cccc voilà
c'est pour cette quelquefois jeu
ça casse un peu par rapport à la classe
politique traditionnelle
vous n'êtes pas des ronds de jambe et
est sûre sur la science moi j'aime la
science j'aime l'entreprise mais j'aime
la science du passé un doctorat vous
avez une formation scientifique dans une
méthodologie brrr mais même regarder
mais même cette histoire de
le x1 ça montre c'est vrai que bon vous
avez vous allez faire des premiers avec
le vélodrome de saint quentin a organisé
une vaccination de masse de paul pour la
population alors même chose j'aime la
science ça c'est juste très très heureux
par exemple est bon et en fait quand
vous regardez la solution de la pandémie
c'est la science qui l'a trouvé en jeu
10 mois andy bord des vaccins alors
qu'avant il fallait 5 à 10 rebonds
ordinaire donc voilà alors maintenant il
s'agit de bien sûr de la produire parce
que c'est bien d'ailleurs créé mais
après faut sur la distribuer il faut
qu'ils ont fait après ensuite et ensuite
et là où vous voyez une nouvelle fois 50
un lien en innovation et montre bien
cette culture et tous les élus suivent
cette culture d'anticiper le vaccin il
est là bon gardien peut enfin il arrive
la prochaine étape c'est quoi c'est un
peu ce qu'on va proposer à saint quentin
dans quelques semaines peut-être
l'accès certes dans les meilleures
conditions mais en plus ça va être un
vaccin plus plus parce que c'est un va
en fait vous accompagner on va faire un
peu une étude d'impact je reproche au
député ou à old trafford faire des lois
et de pas mesuré l'impact après c'est
dans une entreprise vous avez le service
après vente entre guillemets vous
soucier que votre client il bien le
produit
et ben moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse que
le vrai débat ça va plus être taxé
savait que l'immunité
si vous avez une immunité qui dure que
trois mois que c'est ou que six mois ou
que douze mois ou 12 mois on a besoin de
savoir un défenseur qu'elle varia
pourquoi vous seul e devant le même bac
c'est pourquoi vous auriez plus
d'humilité que moi ou le contrat peu
importe et donc on est on va nous suivre
les gens tous les trois mois on va leur
faire une prise de sang voire voir un
peu le niveau
dans leurs anticorps baisse ou pas pour
que vraiment on est une véritable étude
parce que c'est avec ça qu'on pourra
remettre les gens au travail dans saint
quentin est sûr mais pas les gens au
travail dans 50 ans on va avoir de
sacrés problèmes on a dix-sept mille
entreprises on a les plus gros pib par
habitant en france vous imaginez que
bien sûr que les entrepreneurs tous les
salariés ils ont marre aussi les
tchèques donc c'est pas seulement le
vaccin c'est un vaccin que l'on dont on
contrôler l'efficacité c'est ça qu'on va
avoir de plus à saint quentin donc très
pratiquement on va se faire vacciner et
tous les trois mois
on pourra les faire une prise de sang au
vélodrome par exemple ce sera au
vélodrome ou dans le mille en irak al on
est en train de
celle des cadres est pour être sûr qu'on
a les anticorps donc on ne risque pas
d'attraper le virus donc on peut aller
travailler qu'on peut vivre à peu près
normalement vous êtes favorable ou
passeport vaccinale par exemple de toute
façon si on veut être dans ce sens-là
temps et bougez pas encore reçu l'accord
du gouvernement du jeu l'est pour les
vaccins maintenant la deuxième procès
qu'on veut rajouter on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir l'accord du ministre à la santé
bon voilà pourquoi il lui donnerait pas
et donc donc ça c'est vraiment ça c'est
vraiment se soucier de garantir oui de
garantir quelque chose de vrai sur votre
hymne gay parce que si le type pense
qu'il est immunisé et 8 il va voi la
pandémie le monde donc donc ça alors
bien sûr que le passeport
peu importe le terme oui parce que je ne
sais pas si on risque rien n'a rien et
s'ils voulaient relancer les théâtres et
des cinémas les restaurants mais bien
entendu que que que celui qui veut pas
sur maxi ok mais il va falloir il va
falloir clarifier les choses parce qu'on
n'a pas fait laisser mourir l'économie
la culture
tout ça parce que les daims qui sur le
ferait un bon bref
donc de toute façon dans d'autres pays
on y va on voit bien il n'y a pas ça on
n'a pas le choix c'est même pas un choix
affectif au machin c'est une réalité il
faut remettre l'économie formelle la
culture il faut remettre tout en marche
et bien entendu celui qui a on sait
qu'il a ces anticorps l'avait surpris et
on va remettre la vie normale dans la
société française et internationale je
suis pas le seul à partager ça alors il
ya une chose très intéressante dans
cette crise sanitaire
c'est là ce sont les rapports entre
l'état et aux fonds des collectivités
locales on a vu que les collectivités
locales c'était le cas de saint quentin
a pris en charge un certain a pris ses
responsabilités sous le dire c'est vous
qui avez décidé d'ouvrir ce vaccinaux de
robots pour l'appeler comme ça enfin non
dans le vélodrome alors que l'état et
pépette plus en plus réticents ne savait
pas tellement comment comment faire
cesser des pouvoirs quoiqu'il y ait un
problème dans ce pays on va pas se le
cacher c'est se cache pas les problèmes
fin je n'essaye et trouver des solutions
sur l'entreprise on a plutôt de la
solution débusque de les chercher un
coupable comme on veut le saut en
politique ça ça pose beaucoup de fautes
ready solutionnement l'état aujourd'hui
l'état français il devient presque
dangereux pour la france
d'abord il a oublié qu'il est au service
de la france je rappelle que moi je suis
pas au service de l'état les têtes à mon
service enfin on s'est dit mais tous les
mets tous les maires les mains il a 35
mille îles ont une le peuple est
souverain et les ai vus surtout les
mères qui les tribus ils ont cette
souveraineté et pour six ans donc quand
on a quelquefois un ministre qui
s'expriment dont on ne sait pas si dans
six mois ou dans 12 mois risque voilà là
il faudrait quand même peut-être
réapprendre le management un peu plus
horizontal ce que c'est insupportable
les interventions des représentants de
l'état sur les logements sociaux mais ce
que c'est à eux de gérer une gestion de
proximité déjà de gérer de gérer
nos logements sociaux il ya plein de
choses qui sont des décisions de
proximité mais qu'est ce qu'ils
appellent de tous mais qui se mêlent
déjà de ses missions régaliennes
elles sont bien faites ses missions
régaliennes quand on a la france qui est
le pays où les impôts sont les plus
élevés au monde
le pays on travaille le moins au monde
tout ça parce que des gens qui se font
élire en disant aux gens à aller voter
pour moi vous allez moins travaillée ben
voyons mais vous avez vu le système de
santé qui est le plus déclassé le
système d'éducation avec peas est
quelque peu déclassé donc on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça donc l'état il va
falloir qu'il retrouve sa place
d'abord qu'on arrête moi je ne veux plus
voir sur en dehors des missions
régaliennes voire dix représentants de
l'état qui interviennent comme ça sur
les sur les mers je peux vous dire on va
on va casser le il faut arrêter ça parce
que sinon le système va se casser entre
eux les élus qui ont une forte
légitimité et si les mêmes dans les
sondages les élus préférés les défaire
c'est parce que la réalité bien ce n'est
pas de reste is on y voit il son soutien
à leurs prisons qui sont dans leurs
fantasmes dans leur jeu intellectuel
dans dans science po l'ena je veux dire
donc on arrête je suis passé aussi par
cette école
sciences po à bombay mais pas les nuages
sur bon donc voilà il faut il faut
redonner c'est la compétence qui est qui
qui est important est la compétence ça
n'existe pas sans expérience donc tous
ces gens qui confondent un statut haut
niveau de l'état qu'on aurait donné
d'ailleurs quel est l'âge est légitime
de tout ça il ya que la compétence il
faut que l'état prouve sa valeur ajoutée
maintenant mais il faut il faut il fait
des études à paris et dans les cabinets
ministériels on veut 50% de gens qui
vivent dans l'entreprise on veut 50 %
des gens qui nous ressemble qui viennent
de la production des chaises de la
production de solutions
riton ces jeux de dialectique de deux
postures de statut de stratégies de
pouvoir personnel ça il faut arrêter ça
parce que ce pays va être exposition une
vraie révolution n'était que tu veux
réconcilier le terrain c'est-à-dire les
maires avec avec avec l'état français
parce que sinon sa nature c'est que
l'état ne leur mette pas écoulées que
l'état et que l'état soit
accompagnateurs et ne pas et n'ont pas
été faciles et souk chose pour la police
sauf pour la justice mais se mêler c'est
ça c'est des fonctions régaliennes
allumé mais il reste que c'est au maire
de décider c'est pas un état qui est
complètement déconnecté des réalités et
vous voyez sur les genoux ont décidé que
j'ai toute une liste un bon donc voilà
on aime bien tout le monde il faut qu'
il faut se réconcilier mais il faut que
l'état se réconcilie avec le monde de
l'entreprise qu'il ne représente pas
mais c'est quand même les autres
biscuits pour les actions et la richesse
et et les collectivités locales et
territoriales qui eux sont dans l'arrêté
vous regrettez en un mot la qu'emmanuel
mac qu'on n'ait pas été au bout de sa
province n'est pas supprimer les notes
mais comme d'habitude il dit une belle
phrase avec des jolis mots il parle très
bien je suis fasciné quand ils savaient
pas
hirel point tout ça puis après vous
regardez mais dans une entreprise
tiendrait pas parce qu'une entreprise
vous allez juger sur ce que vous avez
fait pas ce que vous avez dit le monde
politique vous êtes juste que vous avez
dit ce qu'on livre est là et c'est pour
ça que j'ai signé pas alors que les
sagas surtout mai mais effectivement
j'ai osé et ça m'a pas fait que des
amitiés de de toute part je ne découvre
un bon mois mais quand j'ai déposé cette
proposition lors il y avait mis une
maxime de de nstein qui disait on
gagnera pour vous pour besoin de moi
pour ce premier n'a einstein disait de
points on ne peut pas résoudre les
problèmes avec les gens qu'ils ont créé
ça a mis de l'engagement il faut le dire
le problème c'est pas pour être un
j'aime c'est pas les gens
que puis-je attaque d'un violon mais
cette école n'a plus de sens c'est une
des écoles les plus archaïques au monde
croit faire croire à ce stade parce
qu'il brillant intellectuellement il va
pouvoir diriger un pays comme la france
en pleine mondialisation
oui elle avait du sang sans doute en 45
quand il fallait reconstruire les
beaucoup moins aujourd'hui un mot pour
terminer sur la situation économique de
de saint quentin avec avec cette crise
sanitaire évidemment ça pose des
problèmes pour les entreprises
est ce que vous sentez quand même quel
là il ya un regain est que que les
choses pourraient rejoindre pour devenir
dans l'ordre si je veux dire dans les
mois qui viennent à moi c'est pour ça
que à 50 ans mobilise avec tous les
maires pour pour qu' on puisse
redémarrer cette super belle machine
c'est une pépite saint quentin en
yvelines
certains d'entre eux patrick jasmin on
sait quand on voit il se dégrader mais
il faut remettre le plus vite possible
les gens qui sont volonté en plus au
travail pour reproduire de la richesse
pour garantir votre retraite parce que
50% des recettes d'une entreprise vont
son redonner à l'état en ce sens fiscal
donc faut bien vous dire que c'est
urgent parce que sinon on déjà votre
retraite et pan dans un bel état
je rappelle encore le texte et voilà
donc il faut il faut et puis la santé si
vous voulez si vous voulez avoir un peu
plus de folie
bien sûr de réanimation et bien regarder
pourquoi l'allemagne est meilleur que
nous sur leye socialisme ce que bell ont
plus d'argent sous donc il faut produire
de la richesse pour redistribuer pour et
d'éducation opérationnel et savent mieux
faire collaborer le public et le privé
aussi peut-être à bord et sa seule cette
espèce d'une guerre larvée entre le
public et privé il faut raquer ça mais
ça coûte ça coûte les 6 millions de
chômeurs ils sont l'avenir le fait que
ces deux mondes se méprisent et et se
comprennent pas c'est pour ça qu'il faut
50% et dans les cabinets et même mes 6
ans chef d'administration directeur
administration on veut 50% de gens qui
viennent de l'entreprise qui ont déjà
réformé quelque chose comment
voulez-vous réformer l'état si vous
laissez des gens qui n'ont jamais
déformé quoi que ce soit et quelque part
ils sont formés à g a géré la situation
et à mai mais ils n'ont pas cette
culture qu'il n'y a pas un chez un
directeur d'une entreprise capa réformer
amont un asservissement possiblement
gars tellement donc il faut mélanger ses
cultures
c'est une ferme mixité culturelle a pour
un peu au niveau de l'état et là
effectivement ce pays retrouvera une
position dans le monde qu'il n'aurait
jamais dû perdre
comment la communauté de saint quentin
évidemment il est ni à des aides de
l'état pour les entreprises comment vous
aidez vous les autres des entreprises à
passer ce cap difficile donne un service
de développement économique à saint
quentin
avec des talents chi chi le qui le
dirige aussi avec moi et je peux vous
dire on est partout sur les petites
entreprises sur les commerces sur sur
vaisseau libye les grandes entreprises
us quand vous voulez aider renault le
même le tour de table c'est plus en
milliards donc la vie république il à
l'état de jouer il joue d'ailleurs
honnêtement on joue bien pour les
finances autant je peux être que saddam
mais honnêtement bien sûr ça augmente la
dette c'est vrai mais ça coûte moins
cher de soutenir que de lâcher j'ai
après de reconstruire bon de toute façon
donc faut laisser catastrophe sociale
le club là dessus le jeu fonctionne
vraiment entre l'état la région qui joue
aussi un rôle très important
et puis nous on développement est là
mais ça fonctionne mais je vous dis pas
qu'on va on va combat tout réseau il ya
un tiers des boîtes qui se sortent très
bien
il ya un tir de bois qui qui qui
souffrent mais qui vont passer entre les
gouttes mais qui souffre qui parle de
l'emploi etc et vous avez tiré droite
qui sont vraiment dangereux avant tout
celle dont vous voyez on est on est on
doit gérer ça ça va être un moment
difficile il faut pas se cacher on est
devant une crise mondiale économique qui
qui va caméras des conséquences
c'est vrai que portait la politique
autrement
ce troc 16 vous va bien non ben oui mais
moi je suis pour réconcilier le monde
économique
mais le monde économique et social je
suis docteur en psychologie sociale vous
dites à l'heure mais je suis né à
montreuil mais bon je connais le social
le social ça n'existe pas sur
l'économique ayant l'économique
ils économisent au service de l'économie
qui doit servir sociale oui mais donc ça
il faudrait confier il faut réconcilier
ces deux ces deux blocs avec l'état et
l'état est au service des français
tout individu qui l'oublieraient à mon
avis sera amené à à ce qu'ils aient une
vie de plus en plus difficiles quelque
chose soit claire et surtout peut nous
mettre dans une impasse donc voilà c'est
je vous rappelle ses c'est important le
peuple est souverain et même s'il a ses
excès de temps en temps ses maladresses
comme tout le monde politique aussi un
bon il faut réconcilier et ce qu'on
attend en français la réconciliation et
surtout que l'état sache se remettre à
sa place il en est sorti
il faut qu'il retrouve sa place merci
beaucoup
[Musique]